good evening everyone thank you for
joining us on such a fine summer evening
my name is Brad T seibel and I'm the
community relations manager here at
barnes noble in pikesville i'm delighted
that so many of you have come out this
evening as I'm sure Gary and his family
are also one of my responsibilities this
community relations manager is to work
with authors local authors traveling
authors who come through the area who
are interested doing a book event and we
get a lot of locals we get a lot of
traveling people but I'm particularly
delighted when we get a local son or
daughter who's done good and comes back
to a very big crowd such as this evening
so please give a very warm welcome to
hometown boy Gary Marcus ah thank you
thank you very much it is always a
pleasure to speak here in Baltimore cuz
as most of you know I grew up here my
family is here tonight my mom and my dad
and it's easy to see how if you know my
mom and my dad how they their influence
has come through my work my dad was
studying the brain before I was even
born my mom is a social worker and as I
put it in the book a lifelong student of
human nature what I've tried to do in
the book is to bring some of these
strands together to bring together the
brain with the mind with jeans and and
tried to figure out what all of those
things mean together so when I left our
fair city of Baltimore and went off to
New England for college and later for
graduate school would I tried to study
what I began the study was cognitive
psychology the science of cognitive
psychology the science of the mind of
how we think and how we reason
eventually in graduate school I turned
to a particular question of thinking and
reasoning which is how do we think and
reason our way into being linguistic
creatures how do we learn to talk human
beings well all we all talk every normal
human being acquires a language and yet
no chimpanzee our closest animal cousin
manages to talk no cat learns to talk
and even though we talk to our plants
they don't talk back there's something
special about
beings that allows them to acquire
language and that's the problem that I
started studying in graduate school and
that led me in part to write this book
one of the things that I discovered in
graduate school was the writings of Noam
Chomsky who probably many of you have
heard about chomsky's idea is the
children are born with the universal
grammar which is some knowledge about
how all of the languages in the world
work so nobody is born knowing English
or knowing Japanese but Chomsky
hypothesized that we might be born
knowing something about what languages
in general are like something that's
shared about all languages some of the
ways in which grammars might work some
of the ways in which different languages
might come to mean different things
Chomsky's idea is essentially that
there's a set of brain circuits that we
might call the language acquisition
device that a child is born with this
language acquisition device would be
something that only humans have and the
would allow us uniquely to acquire
language so John skeeza position is a
theoretical position which he reached by
comparing the world's languages studying
other people who did that there are
different ways to try to understand this
idea of whether a child might be born
with there's a child right there um in
doing a little language practice even as
we speak Chomsky's idea ah was that we
were born with this language acquisition
device you could try to study that
experimental you could try to do studies
to look at what it is the children
actually do and try to see whether
there's any sign that anything is
built-in so what I did in graduate
schools i work with Steven Pinker who
some of you might know from his books
and Steven Pinker and I looked at how
children acquire simple things like the
English past tense so the English past
tense is made up of a very simple system
there are irregular verbs like sing sang
and go went each of which is
unpredictable has its own past tense
form and then there are regular verbs
like walk walked and talked talked and
the child has to learn what those rules
are so if you learn a foreign language
as an adult you might memorize some
lists or something like that a child has
to acquire this system children often
makes mistakes in this system and that
was part of what I said
in graduate school what we did initially
was we did a study we had these
transcripts of children talking to their
parents so they were like movie scripts
except about very mundane topics and we
looked at when do children actually make
these mistakes when did they say things
like braked instead of broke so it's as
an adult we just get the past tense
right we do it automatically without
thinking about it we say sang is the
past tense of sting we don't have to
think about a bit a child will sometimes
say sing instead of saying this is
called an over regularization air and
there were rumors in the literature and
this taught me the value of counting and
looking the rumors in the literature in
the professional literature the children
went through a stage where they made
these mistakes all the time and it sort
of seems that way if you're a parent if
you have a little kid who's 3 or 4 years
old you'll notice when the child says I
sing door I braked it or I hold the baby
rabbits or something like that but it
turns out that you won't notice when
your child gets it right when the child
says I sang yesterday or I held the baby
rabbits you don't really notice that
then you're paying attention to what
they're talking about instead of how
they were saying it so as we started to
actually look at what children are
really saying we found that the mistakes
were actually pretty rare and they were
systematic children only made the
mistakes for verbs that they didn't have
very much exposure to so basically
children at the age of three and four
that we're looking at already had
mastered this particular aspect of the
grammar they made a few mistakes here
and there that seemed very dramatic but
when you look more carefully I turned
out they basically understood the system
it's a system that has what we call a
default it's a last resort so if you
don't know the right past tense for a
particular verb you can always add ed to
it so if I ask you what's the past tense
of the verb dish end which means to
shame most of you would say the past
tense is SH ended you know why not just
a DD to and treated like a regular verb
but if you look in the dictionary end
which means the shame has the past tense
of shent so technically speaking you
would have over regularize din just the
way the children do adding D is your
last resort in it's the last resort of a
three-year-old it's just the
three-year-old doesn't have the benefit
of all the experience with the correct
form so if I told you shent a few times
as the past sense of shame you would
learn it pretty quickly the children
learn it quickly it's just they're less
experienced but they have the same
overall grammatical
the man aged three or four so pretty
early in life as an adult does that was
a kind of work that I did in graduate
school and then when i became a junior
faculty member for State University of
Massachusetts and then at New York
University people started developing
good techniques for studying younger and
younger children and so I studied
younger and younger children for the
question of language so one of the
studies that I did just to give you an
example was I looked at seven month old
babies and I wanted to know can they
break into the language game at seven
months so they're not actually talking
yet but can they understand anything
about what's going on around them can
they try to learn a grammar that they
hear so we made of artificial grammars
very simple grammar so see if children
could get into the game so I would play
for the children sentences produced by a
computer that all followed a simple rule
the ABA rule so a meteor sentences like
lata la gana gah me Tommy and so forth
for about two minutes I mean you're an
adult it gets quite repetitive and quite
boring very quickly another lot allah
down on me Tommy and you're running for
the door then we did after giving kids
two minutes to hear these just two
minutes that's it to hear these
sentences we gave him some new sentences
some of those new sentences had the same
grammar wolf a whoa was the same thing
they were hearing before it's not really
that different just a different set of
words well Faye Faye was a different
grammar the abb grammar and our question
was could they tell the difference
between them the way that we did this we
wanted to know how long they would
listen to these things but we can't
measure where their ears are pointed to
so we measured where their eyes were
pointed if you're wondering about that
so we had flashing lights on two sides
of the room one of which had one kind of
sound coming out and other which had
another and we measured how long babies
were looking at the flashing lice and
what we discovered is they paid more
attention when they heard something with
a new grammar so when they heard whoa
Feifei the abb grammar they perked up
they paid more attention so that was at
seven months old it led me to write
another book called the algebraic mine
the idea was that these babies were
actually doing a kind of algebra they'd
learned an abstract equation that
governed the sentences in the language
that we gave them so you know you can
think in algebra x equals y plus 2 and
you find out what Y is and then you
oculi with exes for that's the heart of
algebra well they were basically doing
something like that they were saying one
of these sentences can be an a followed
by be followed by another a and 7 months
old they may not unconscious of what
they were doing but they were able to
pick up this basic grammar um this guy
picked up in the news my favorite
headline was scientists go gaga over boo
boo
now at this point the results from the
Human Genome Project were just coming in
at this point I would still pretty much
except cognitive psychologists I hadn't
really explored biology but I was
starting to get very interested in the
biology of genetics because genetics is
ultimately what this whole question of
universal grammar or language
acquisition device is about if Chomsky
is right if there's something built-in
in my own experimental data seem to
support Chomsky's idea well Chomsky was
right that there's something built in
then you've got to eventually turn to
the genes to try to figure out what is
it that's built in how is it that genes
could construct a brain now if you
remember when the Human Genome Project
the first reports of its completion came
out the biggest discovery was that there
were fewer genes than people thought so
one biologist had made up a number in a
very well-read textbook number was a
hundred thousand and that got spread
around because nobody else had any idea
what the real number was and then the
human genome project was completed or
actually they've said about three or
four times it's completed if they really
mean it's ninety percent complete 99
percent complete and so forth but we've
converged on the truth that they're only
about 30,000 genes the relatively small
number of genes certainly fewer than
anybody except ever expected now let's
go back to Chomsky for a second if
Chomsky is right and there's something
special about the human brain that
allows us to learn language while all
that complexity in the brain has to come
from somewhere right Chomsky saying
there's specific brain circuits in the
human brain not in the chimpanzee brain
not in the cat rain but in the human
brain specific brain circuits that are
there from birth that allow us to
acquire language and my own experimental
results seem consistent with that idea
but there are 20 billion neurons in the
brain and only 30,000 genes this is a
big difference how do you get from point
A to point B I think that some critics
of Chomsky's idea Chomsky certainly has
its critics figured that this must mean
if they're only 30 thousands that have a
hundred thousand genes the Chomsky must
be three times more wrong than ever
before
now lucky for me right about this time I
got my first sabbatical a year off from
teaching and even more lucky to turn to
be two years from teaching because I was
able to be a fellow at the Center for
Advanced Studies in stanford california
and so i had two years in which to try
to retrain myself and this book the
birth of the mind is really a product of
what I did during that time what I
learned as I tried to connect the human
genome to these questions about what is
built into the mind of a child so I
wanted to understand how do you get from
point A to point B how do you get from
30,000 genes to 20 billion neurons where
does the environment fit in what is an
individual gene do questions like that
now I don't obviously have time today to
tell you the whole story that's what the
book is for but I wanted to tell you a
few of the most important things that I
discovered as I tried to connect biology
to these psychological questions of what
the structure of the mind of a newborn
child might be like the first one that
I'd like to explain to you is a very
simple idea I want to replace one one
idea that we get all the time from the
media that isn't quite right and it
really changes things so when I tell you
there's only 30,000 genes and those 20
billion neurons it sort of seems like
well the genes can't really be that
important after all right 30,000 of
these 20 billion of those it must not be
that important well the reason it seems
like the jeans couldn't be all that
important is because we imagine the
genome to be a blueprint and in fact
every time we read a magazine article or
newspaper article that talks about the
genes we get this idea of the genome is
a blueprint right we get this idea that
each gene would correspond to a
particular part of the brain or a
particular part of the neuron and that
basically your destiny would be spelled
out in your genome now that doesn't
really fit with our everyday experience
we know for example that identical twins
behave very similarly so we know that
the genes are important because they
share genes but they're also not
identical we know that experience
matters environment matters it's really
not right to think of the genome as a
blueprint I think in fact a better way
to think about it is a recipe and in
fact a special kind of recipe so the
genome instead of saying this thing must
be in this way and this thing must be in
that way
i instead the genome each one of those
jeans is actually individually like a
recipe it actually has two parts so part
of it is a recipe for how you build a
particular protein so every gene builds
a different protein some of the most
familiar ones are things like the
collagen and our lips and the keratin in
our hair but there are all kinds of
proteins there are hundreds of thousands
of different kinds of proteins because
each gene can actually make more than
one they build much of the substance of
the body so after you take away the
water protein is one of the most
important components for the body so
every gene is like a recipe it says how
to make this particular protein but it
also is a special kind of recipe I like
to think of it like a line in the
computer program if you'll forgive me
piling on the metaphors so in a computer
program you have an if and it then this
is the heart of every bit of software
that you've ever used our rules that say
things like if your balance if the check
exceeds the amount in your balance then
warn the user that the user is about to
bounce the check you know there's an if
and then every bit of software is if
this thing happens then do this other
thing well every gene is like that
rather than just saying blindly build
this protein no matter what no matter
what the environment is like every gene
actually has two parts one part says if
something is true then go ahead and
build this protein that's enormous
consequence because it means that what
the genome does is not blind but
responsive to the environment wherever
there's an if there's at least in
principle possibility that evolution
could have evolved a gene to be
responsive to the environment in some
way one of my favorite examples of this
that I've given the book is there's a
particular butterfly the basic list
butterfly and what's interesting about
this butterfly as it grows into two
totally different forms depending on
which season it develops so the genes
they are acting like switches they say
if it's this um the rainy season then
you should be this very bright colorful
version that will blend in with all the
other leaves if you're in the hot dry
season then you should develop into a
brown butterfly and then you blend in
with all this stuff the proof of this is
you can take a butterfly in any season
and raise it in the laboratory and you
move the temperature up and down and you
can control how the butterfly will
develop so in the butterfly genome
is a set of genes that don't dictate you
must do this you must do that but rather
say if there's this kind of
circumstances and do this kind of thing
if there's this other kind of
circumstance to this other kind of thing
I think this is the most fundamental
thing that people have to understand
about genes you won't see it I think in
most newspaper articles or most magazine
articles about biology won't even see it
in a lot of books that are about
evolution and things like that it's not
common it's not really that difficult an
idea but it really changes how we think
about the nature of our genetic
endowment it means that it doesn't
dictate but rather gives us options I
think that's one of the most fundamental
ideas in in biology and it's really
important to understanding the mind and
the brain because all of these if thenns
conspire not just to build our body we
think of genes as being about the body
but also to build our brain so a certain
part of the book is about what are the
particular genes that help guide the
brain so I'm not going to go into a lot
of detail here but basically brain cells
are just sells your brain is made up of
cells like any other part of the body
and individual cells are a little bit
like children we had another metaphor if
you don't mind in that they first have
to they do a number of things they
divide multiply they differentiate so
they take on particular jobs sometimes
they move away from their homes so every
every cell has a particular sort of
lifestyle particular set of things that
it does that depends on its environment
so you can take a cell from one part of
the body move it to a different part of
the body will do different things
because it will start to follow
different recipes different ifs and
different then are applicable in
different kinds of places and all of
this is exactly as true in the brain as
it is everywhere else so one of the
stunning discoveries of the last decade
is the extent to which the toolkit of
biology that's evolved over over all
these millennia is exactly the same in
the brain as the body from the
perspective of biology building a brain
is really just growing one more organ
it's like growing a heart or growing a
liver so the way that the genes build
the heart is the same way as the
building a brain 30,000 genes isn't a
problem for the heart the hearts are
very complex organ and it's not a
problem for the bringing either each of
these genes by having these complicated
programs if this is true then we can do
this other thing leads to an enormous
amount of food black city another
fundamental idea about genes that I'd
like you to take home is just the notion
that the individual genes don't have a
simple relationship to traits so we
often think going back to the idea of
Mendel that you'd have one gene for one
particular trait and the book I have
this lovely cartoon where there are
genes for particular things like a gene
for the delusions of stock market
grandeur or a gene for the for
propensity pardon me to talk about the
weather this is a nice fanciful idea and
it actually is based in a bit of
scientific history Mendel was the first
person to really identify the idea that
there must be genes he didn't actually
know anything about DNA which is what
genes of course made of but he proved
mathematically that there must be
something like jeans and in the simple
experiments he did with breeding
different tea plants it was a pretty
good first approximation to say that
you've got one gene for one trade but in
a complex organism like a human being it
doesn't really work that well you've got
these genes that build proteins but
there are many proteins that are
involved in any particular trait those
proteins can be influenced by the
environment and so forth so again it's
better to think of the genome as this
recipe of offense the special
self-guided recipe where each individual
cell can actually follow a different set
of those recipes right well one thing is
that um every every cell in the body has
a complete copy of this grand library of
30,000 genes but each cell does
something differently that again brings
us back to the offense so each cell is
following its own set of if ends they've
got the complete set of genes but only
some of them are applicable to the
function of that cell if you're a neuron
you follow the recipes that are
appropriate for neuron if you're a liver
cell then you follow the recipes that
are appropriate for their now that may
or may not be more about neuro
embryology than you are hoping to learn
this evening there's more detail where
that came from in the book including
lovely examples about for example how a
single neuron connects to another neuron
the brain is all about communication the
neurons the nerve cells have to talk to
another and evaluate things and so it's
all important how they're wired together
if you mess up with the wiring of the
brain brain doesn't work anymore and the
major challenge and development in the
womb is for the brain to get wired up
properly and in the book I talk about
how the individual neurons send out
axons that connect to other neurons and
how they find their way all the kinds of
signalling systems they're kind of
highway systems in the brain I talk
about that kind of thing but I'm going
to leave that kind of detail for the
book because I want to just bring up one
more topic and then I'm going to take
questions about anything you'd like to
ask about genes and behavior and brains
and so forth but the last thing I want
to talk to you about is a kind of
revolution that I think is coming and
revolution I think most people want to
hide from I don't think we really can
hide from instead we should try to make
the best of it that we can the
revolution that I'm talking about is of
course the genetic revolution so we had
the atomic age in the computer age but
what's coming is that scientists are
going to be able to manipulate the
genome we can already read the genome
pretty well we can figure out all the
letters in an individual's genetic
sequence and eventually we're going to
be able to if we want to to actually
manipulate individual gene scientists
can already do this in the lab with
animals this is a scary prospect but I
think that our first temptation is to
just run away and say forget it don't do
it let's ban it all together let's not
have any genetic engineering and so
forth I think that that's probably a
mistake I think for example that people
are much too afraid of genetically
modified food and that could actually
solve some of the world's hunger
problems but story for another day and
not my own specialty but I think the
fact of the matter is these techniques
are available and people are going to
start to use them for good or for evil
and then we need to think seriously
about what what what happens when you
change an individual gene the first
thing that I'd like to make you aware of
is although we have have the technology
almost at hand to actually change
individual genes we what we don't have
is the knowledge about what's going to
happen and the reason for that is that
individual genes work together so there
are 30,000 of these genes but each one
of these genes can control other genes
so as I mentioned each team builds
approaching well proteins can actually
serve as the trigger for another gene so
one jeans
which builds a protein can guide the if
of another gene that guides another gene
who's the old clairol commercial and
they told to friends and they told to
friends and so on and so on it's just
like that old commercial you have this
avalanche where one protein can
influence another and another and so
forth so if you change one gene you may
know what happens there you can say for
sure there's going to be more of this
protein if i change this gene so that
it's always on for example this is an
experiment with mice where they turned
on it made a gene the control cell
division stay on forever cell division
in the brain well what happened in these
mice they had bigger brains instead of
sort of like the Sorcerer's Apprentice
instead of making you know seven rounds
of cell division in a normal-sized brain
there were 20 rounds of cell division or
something like that an enormous brain
biologists don't yet know if I had any
psychological consequence but we can in
principle do these kinds of experiments
now but the problem is we don't know
what's downstream so we don't know if we
influenced this gene what the other
genes are going to do so we have this
powerful technology but that doesn't
guarantee us that we're going to know
the consequences um so we need to bear
this in mind as we advance through the
technology but even if I said oh it's
very scary we should abandon it some
people would use it anyway for example
think about athletes who are already
playing around with things like human
growth hormone so I think that these
kinds of technologies are going to be
used and what I hope is that we'll try
to find good uses for them as well as
try to find ways of legislating so that
they're not put too bad uses and I want
to end the talking part today with a
kind of radical idea for one way which I
don't think anybody else is thought of
for how we could possibly use genes to
do something worthwhile if a little bit
scary so remember back to this idea that
genes are more like switches then than
just dictating things well if you read
time or Newsweek you might have once or
twice seen a gene called mao-a which has
something to do with violence and the
way that it was reported in the news
media was essentially this is a gene for
violence right this is always what you
see in the media this is the gene for
obesity this is the gene for violence
this is the gene for telling funny jokes
and so forth and so on well it's
actually much more subtle with this
particular gene
what this particular gene does is it
behaves like one of these switches if
you raised in a normal environment it
doesn't lead you to be any more prone to
violence than anybody else if you're
raised in a certain kind of stressful
abusive environment then it leads to a
greater propensity for violence right so
from an evolutionary perspective it
might actually make sense that you have
this kind of switch that prepares you
sort of for feast or famine to behave in
a different way in case of famine so the
radical idea and the unsettling idea
that I want to close the talking part of
this with is we could actually use this
kind of knowledge to do something that's
a little bit like what doctors call
pharmacogenetics so what doctors do
nowadays at least a little bit and we'll
do more and more is they prescribe drugs
based on people's individual genetic
profile so they can say this kind of
drug is more appropriate for you this
one would cause you side effects but
wouldn't cause somebody else side
effects because of the particular
protein chemistry of your particular
body so at least in principle we could
imagine having social interventions made
specially available to people that were
specially at risk so if you have a
particular version of this gene that
makes you especially susceptible to
violence in particularly abusive
circumstances we could for example
direct home visit resources or something
like that to the people who might need
the most don't expect you all to agree
with that that can be one of the many
things that you asked questions about I
want to thank you very much for coming
I'm very delighted to take any questions
you might have about biology and how it
relates to the mine thank you very much
before I take questions um because we're
being recorded I think there's a
microphone and we're going to bring the
microphone around so don't ask your
question till you get the microphone it
looks like the first hand was how long
lasting is the effect of the by Madonna
gene on it canopy for life I mean one
one thing is the question was how long
can can environment effect genes in some
animals for example in the butterfly
example it's really for life it's a
switch there that controls how this
particular animal is going to develop
and that's a lifetime consequence for
the animal doesn't again change its
pattern later in the season for violence
so suppose you have somebody who's
brought up has a very abusive childhood
he then reaches Tina his teenage years
his environment doesn't change much but
is he goes older somehow or another he
strikes it rich moves out someplace
where he doesn't have that abusive weird
environment does he still remain a
variable we don't really know the answer
the question is a great question and
it's probably going to have different
answers for different genes so there are
ways for example in which genes can
stabilize themselves so once a gene
switches on it may stay on there are
other genes where the body actually
tries to regulate them so they don't
stay on the body has different kinds of
mechanisms things like feedback loops
that can maintain gene so they last a
long time other genes the transitory so
they can do one process like rebuild one
particular thing and not last so I I
can't answer in this particular case and
in the general case the answer is going
to be we don't know until we go out and
look there are cases like fish where you
can have one battle between two fish for
dominance and that will immediately
change a whole bunch of genes that might
then be able to switch back if the
battle goes the other way so if you win
you switch on a whole bunch of different
genes this is nature and nurture working
together the this fish is switching its
behavior because of a whole bunch of
genes of switch but they can probably
switch back if the fish again changes
from being dominant and submissive or
the other way around so they're probably
all ranges of answers from
that only have effects that last for
half a second the genes that last a
lifetime and there's a lot more to be
discovered about that excellent when you
were talking you were talking about one
gene changing another changing another
on the mark steiner show you spoke about
the cascade effect is that what you
meant I have have there been experiments
where you could kind of change them down
the line as they change I don't think
we're fast enough yet I mean maybe in
principle one could do that at our
current understanding of genetics and
the technology that we have to work with
genetics it's not easy to actually
figure out the whole cascade so one of
the best examples in biology of have one
of these cascades works is in the fruit
fly there's a single gene that if you
turn it on in the right place you can
grow an extra eye it's a gene that's at
the top of the Cascade for building eyes
it's not really right to call it the I
gene that would be much too simple it's
really a gene that says something like
build an eye here and one of the most
amazing experiments of the last few
years says they took the mouse version
of this gene a lot of genes are shared
across different species that took the
mouse version of this in a fruit fly put
it on the antennae of a fruit fly and
the fruit fly grew an extra eye on its
antennae now it wasn't just that one
gene because it wasn't a mouse I it was
a fruit fly I so what it did is it
recruited all the other fruit fly jeans
for building eyes their estimates that
are about 2,500 of those involved and
what scientists tried to do is nowadays
is they'll do experiments like they'll
say well what if we take out this gene
we can create a mouse that doesn't have
this gene known as pack six and we can
see what changes and we can try to work
out which other genes don't get turned
on as a consequence but it's very slow
work you can take a year to build one
mouse that does this and that will tell
us something about sort of the next
level but you can imagine what you're
trying to do is to figure out a
corporate hierarchy of all of the genes
involved in say building an eye or
building some part of the brain that
gene actually works in both you're
trying to figure out the whole corporate
hierarchy and you can kind of it takes
you a year to figure out you know who
the first level manager is that reports
to the chief executive and it's gonna
take you another year to work your way
down the next level there may avenge
be better technologies that allow us to
do that better one technology that come
out allows us to measure a whole bunch
of jeans at the same time not the
relations between them but just say how
many which of these 30,000 genes are
actually active in this cell at this
particular moment so you know 30 years
from now we might be able to sort of
follow all the downstream consequences
but right now we can't we know they're
there but we can't directly measure them
Gary um what are the implications that
with the birth of my mind well that's
exactly what I'm thinking care i was
going to ask what are the implications
of your work for education and i'm
thinking of you as a youth because i'm
just going to take a one brief minute
here but the aerial embarrassment coming
on not going to be embarrassed but i
think it's a real question in education
because gary is one of the smartest kids
I've ever worked with and I had the
pleasure of working with him for three
years but it was in a special program
for gifted and talented children and
some of the regular classroom teachers
didn't think he was so brilliant because
he like he couldn't wait right my way
out but good man you couldn't read his
writing I realized that that was all on
the side because I saw what was going in
Harry's head and that was what was
exciting to me about the Gary but my
question is what about the implications
of your work for education and for you
know you're talking about gene switching
on and off what if certain of your genes
have been switched off at a young age
because you couldn't write well and you
would you know are there any
implications in your work Gary I think
they're there um throw to him at least
two implications one is that biologists
and social scientists and educators and
so forth should start working together
much more than they ever have I think
there's traditionally biology and
education have been seen as sort of
antithetical and examples like the mao-a
gene that I was talking about thinking
leads to violence and particular
circumstance there going to be more
examples like this if people do the
right kinds of research and I certainly
hope there will and those can serve as a
guide the other thing is there's no
doubt that it
experience and stimulation are critical
for getting the right genes to do the
right kinds of things that doesn't
really lead to any specific suggestions
for curriculum design in the immediate
future I think in the long term future
if people do more research on what we
call gene environment interactions I
think there's rich possibility that we
could do things like find something
better about curricula fine for example
how much stimulation is right so I
always get asked this question about
sort of Mozart babies you know should
should we play all this classical music
and I don't really know the answer I
sort of try to bluff my way through it
but I mean the answer is something like
we know that a laboratory animal that
gets no stimulation does very poorly in
a laboratory animal that gets decent
stimulation which they call the enriched
environment does much better but we
don't know if that means a super
enriched environment for human being is
a really good thing so we might
eventually be able to do research into
questions like that as we better
understand some of the genetic
mechanisms we can use them as diagnostic
tools eventually and so forth I think
the general notion that good teachers
have always known is that you've got to
try to suit the teaching to the
individual needs of the student I think
that this is one more reason to believe
you know what good teachers have known
all along that that different kids are
are different they're going to have
different learning mechanisms built into
their brains because their genes are
expressed in different ways and that's
going to give different opportunities
for each I thank you hi Gary um you had
mentioned earlier that we don't know
when we change a gene we don't know what
the rippling effects of that will be
doesn't that argue a lot against moving
forward very quickly in this I are used
for moving with great caution i don't i
don't think it argues for not moving at
all no presentation I a great caution
epsilon I might agree with you on that
but but also what are the ethics then
involved are you do you dabble in that
at all I mean I Develin it only mostly
indirectly which is one of the reasons
that I wrote the book was to inform
people about what the biology is and how
it relates to the mind I didn't want to
take a stand myself I don't think I'm
qualified as an emphasis but I wanted to
raise the issues and the last chapter in
the book is really in part about the
south
issues and then there's an appendix
that's also about kind of the
methodologies and what are the limits on
the methods would what are we likely to
be able to figure out soon what's going
to take us a longer time to figure out
and so forth I think that scientists
have an obligation to participate in
discussions about the ethics but I don't
think they should overstep their bounds
and assume that they know more about
ethics then the next person as I said on
the radio show yesterday I think that
what's really important is we need to
start now before the technology is fully
developed thinking about having
committees are not just think about but
actually having committees that are made
up of scientists of ethicists and also
of lay people and I hope that my book
can at least contribute to the
discussion but I don't want to try to
answer it myself wild restore start one
of those groups if I get enough emails i
can start something on the web I don't
Jerry I was under I was under the
impression that are they take many years
to change change coming for genes to
change like for instance in our Africa
there was a malaria sold sickle cell was
developed by the body but this took many
years and now for for some black
Americans it's a is devastating yeah I
mean sickle cell anemia and the relation
to malaria is a really interesting case
that goes actually to the last question
which is one of the reasons that we
shouldn't sort of leap headfirst into
changing the genes is often a gene that
seems in some way to be bad has some
kind of positive consequence to so all
of our genes other things being equal or
the product of evolution and and have
other things being equal conveyed some
kind of advantage there there for a
reason in general so in that particular
case if you have this gene that has a
propensity leads you to a propensity to
sickle cell anemia it also conveys
advantage to malaria an exam protect you
from malaria an example that I give in
the book is we know how to make quote
smart mice now and I don't get excited
an event I'm not going to advise you
take any medication at home it turns out
that these mites they're not that smart
they do a little bit better on some
tasks of short-term memory and
you know that would be nice but it also
turns out that by changing this
particular receptor in the brain that
these mice are actually more sensitive
to pain so you've got something that you
know we know kind of what the dial is to
affect the quality of the memory but we
don't know what else is tied to the same
dial and well now we know at least one
other thing that is is is is a
sensitivity to pain so often a single
gene will actually be used in many
places I know you still haven't answered
your question a single gene may be used
in many places evolution is totally
capricious if there's a gene that will
get one job done it's sort of lying
around evolution might apply it to some
other jobs is another reason we need to
be cautious your question was really
about the rate at which genes change and
in general they don't change very fast
they change when there's reproduction
than jeans scramble around and there can
be other sources of mutation but they
change over generations not you know
within a generation but that's changing
with technology so I mean it's only
changing because we have the technology
for better or something of six million
dollar man we have the technology but we
have the technology where we can now
take a mouse and change it takes a year
but we can change something about its
genetic complement that will get passed
along so so I mean this is going to
totally change things because there are
all these new possibilities and part of
what I'm advocating is not that we take
them or that we don't but that we think
about what's on the table what are the
possibilities what could happen what
what good could happen what bad could
happen I think because the technology is
out there we've got to start reckoning
with it Garrett's been about 20 years
since I read any of this literature in
grad school but there was a lot of work
done okay there was a lot of work done
with hemispherical dominance and then
finding the language had developed in
different areas of the brain one of the
theories it was being used with it
different areas of brain were ready to
learn language at different points in
time of this individuals development do
you think there's a case for kind of
working on the behavioral side to
identify differences in gene see how it
turns out
and maybe that would be a softer
approach and well I mean there are a lot
of roaches at different scientists are
taking one of the most exciting things
in the last couple of years so people
are trying to bring together genetic
technology with brain imaging technology
so you're really talking about how do we
localize particular parts of the brain
particular functions to particular parts
of the brain how do we know you know
which parts of the brain are even
involved in something like language and
I'll tell you right now we don't know
for sure the answer to that question
we've known for a long time the places
like Broca's area is on the left side of
the brain are really important for
language but we're discovering that a
lot of the brain is involved in language
the simple idea of sort of one spot in
the brain one function is probably not
right or at least not in terms of the
kinds of functions that we tend to think
about them they're going to be more
abstract functions their kinds of
computations because of mathematical
operations that the frame does that the
localizer particular area so is going to
be complicated is the short answer to
figure out what parts of the brain are
involved in particular task with what I
was going to say in response to your
question is there there's now work where
people try to tie together the genetics
with the neuroimaging with the brain
imaging and try to figure out for
example is there any relation between
how your brain is organized and the
kinds of genes that you have so you can
do this in live human beings
non-invasively you can take pictures of
how the brain responds to different
kinds of stimuli and also take blood
samples and find out something about the
genetic material and try to work between
the two to try to understand things so
absolutely you don't want to use as your
only scientific technique for
understanding how the brain works
experimenting by changing the genes and
as much as possible you want to use
non-invasive techniques to try to
discover what's going on by measuring a
brain without actually changing it in
any way and they're better and better
techniques for doing that
very i'm guessing that your interest and
expertise in genetics is sort of a
recent development that you didn't start
out in genetics that's right i started
out in psychology and cognitive science
and i only started really getting
interested in the biology after i kept
over and over again seeing evidence that
the child really was born something i
want to understand what that was about
so are you self taught in genetics um to
a certain extent I mean I've talked with
many of the you know great leaders in
the field but um but I used this time
when I had a sabbatical a few years ago
to retrain in that field another
question could you just talk briefly
about inheritance hallelujah if then so
I mean what you inherit is a set of
genes and so what you're inheriting is
this set of the offense you're going to
get some of those offense from your
mother and some of those if tens from
your father you're going to get sort of
a different recipe book than either one
of them had but more or less all that
you inherit is that set of offense i say
more or less because they're always
finding out something new for example
the mother actually passes on a few
clues about which of those recipes you
should use so not only do you get ifs
and thence from from both your parents
but there are things that call
epigenetic states that control some of
what's initially on you might have sort
of indirectly guessed that if you paid
attention to the clone literature so we
have for example Dolly the sheep and
Dolly the sheep looked pretty much like
the place the donor from which Dolly was
grown but dolly didn't last very long
valley live maybe four or five years I
don't I'm not up on my sheep I don't
know how much shorter that is but in
general all of the clones have been
aging very quickly and you'd say well if
they have the same genes and then pretty
much have the same diet why are they
aging differently it seems to boil down
to this stuff called epigenetic
information which is these hints that
you get that are in the egg itself the
start some of the genes is on in some of
them off and if you again think back to
well one gene can influence another and
another and another then even turning on
a few genes in the beginning to give a
hint could be really important we don't
understand the mechanics of that yet of
how these
get passed along with what they are and
we don't know how to copy them and so
forth somebody else have a question
raise your hand
I have a question I'm not sure how to
ask it I guess I'm thinking how does all
this knowledge about genes and the
switches and the environment affecting
it have implications for understanding
and maybe treatment of something like
depression um I think that there are
many lessons from genetics to disorders
some sort of hopeful and some that
require patience I guess so I mean the
first lesson is that probably many
disorders are I mean this is no surprise
are responsive to the environment some
way and we may eventually understand
better the ways in which their responses
to the environment which may lead either
to treatments for people now or at least
you know techniques that we can prevent
the onset of certain disorders later
that's one of the lessons another lesson
though is that disorders are in general
going to be harder to figure out than I
think the media would lead you to
believe so probably some people are
already i don't think i've already seen
a bit of backlash it's like hey you got
the whole genome we spend whatever we
spend was at a billion dollar so i'm not
sure and you know there I haven't been a
lot of diseases that have been cured
well that's because the genes are all
working together there are some
disorders that are caused by a single
gene those are the most tractable
they're probably about five thousand of
them there you can actually find them
online at online Mendelian inheritance
in man oh I am omim dot org I believe it
is they will tell you about all these
single gene disorders and astonishing
number of them I mean almost any gene if
something goes wrong with that gene then
there's a consequence right the genes
are set the way they are mostly because
their nap too but many of the disorders
that we think about the most that
they're the most common things like
depression and schizophrenia and so
forth are actually caused by the
interaction of many genes as well as by
the environment in the methodology kind
of appendix of the book I talk about
some of the complexities and figuring
out what gene is related to a particular
disorder and if there's only a single
gene this is the part where I think the
lesson is that we need a lot of patience
if there's a single gene it's relatively
easy to figure it out a guy named
Sturdivant actually figured out
mathematics of it in I think 1912 when
he was about 20 years old for how you
could track down do what he called
genetic mapping or some people call
walking the genome genes tend to travel
together but they travel together less
likely the further they are away on the
chromosome and so you can use that
mathematics to identify by looking at
pedigrees how people are related in
toulon a family has a disorder to track
down these single gene disorders and
figure out where the gene is that might
cause a disorder that has just one gene
underlying it but when there are many
genes we just don't have any really good
techniques we can do these kinds of
correlational studies but correlational
studies always remind us the causation
and correlation are not the same thing
this is a great deal of difficulty you
need enormous sample sizes so the whole
population of Finland or something like
that to try to track these things down
it's very difficult and techniques will
probably get better and better as people
understand what's common across genomes
more and more they start to understand
some of the patterns in which there's
variation within groups and between
groups and helps narrow these things
down but we're still a long way from
really being able to identify with
certainty for the genetic substrates for
these disorders and then there's one
more lesson which is that most these
disorders that aren't caused by one gene
they're actually going to be different
versions of so a good example is
attention deficit disorder that's
defined by you don't have this problem
you don't have this problem and so forth
which probably really is a sign that
there are several different things going
on that are sort of for convenience
lumped into one category but probably
many different people with bitter
identified as having attention deficit
disorder actually have different kinds
of genetic deficits or altered genomes
and that's going to mean that they're
each going to need to be treated
differently and so forth in terms of
pharmacology so yet another thing we
need to be patient for but we can be a
little bit optimistic about is as we
understand a bit more about how multiple
genes can cause a disorder and how there
can be different variations as we can
screen for different variations we can
do this pharmacogenetic thing where we
can say well you know ritalin will make
sense for this person because they have
this kind of receptor this kind of
dopamine system but it's not going to
make sense for this other kind of person
because this is
other thing going on so slowly we're
going to do a lot better and being able
to diagnose and to treat disorders but
it's not going to be overnight by any
stretch with a question back there in
the genetic studies or all the animal
studies begun at birth or pre-birth or
are there some that are interventionist
that to go on after but everything under
the Sun these days some of the most
amazing studies to me remember I said
you got an if and then well nowadays you
can actually cut and paste like there
were microsoft word document if you have
the right tools so you can take the if
from one gene and relate it to the then
of another chain one example this just
to give you a silly example is but very
useful part useful then I'll get to the
silly part um the useful part is you can
take a gene from a jellyfish that makes
a fluorescent protein you can hook it up
to the if of any gene so any gene that
you want to know well where in the body
does this gene get used you take the
jellyfish protein you hook it up to the
if and then it shines in all the right
places the silly use is somebody did
this with alba the glowing baby bunny so
that as an art project they took an if
that's expressed in every cell in the
body or every cell on the skin i'm not
quite sure how they did it and attached
it to this phosphorescent protein in
elbow if you stick them i think it's a
he under a blacklight below perhaps not
the best use of the technology um but
the more general point is you can take
ifs that are responsive for example to
antibiotics and then you can do things
like you want to know does this gene
affect memory and you can apply the
antibiotic in the lifetime of say a
mouse and a specific moment and say well
when I trigger this gene at you know age
one year just before this mouse runs a
maze does it make a difference for the
ability for the mouse to run the maze so
by using if they're actually time
sensitive and then if that our location
sensitive you can say well what if I
turn on this gene in this particular
place at this particular time what will
happen there so a few years ago you were
lucky if you could build what they call
a knockout mouse that would have the
gene knocked out for the entire lifetime
of that um that was
real scientific advance but it wasn't
enough because you know if you don't
have the gene for the whole lifetime the
gene plays the role in 40 different
things and it's a very vague way to
figure out what's going on as they can
use the IFS as a tool and pin point in
time and space you have a much better
chance to figure out what a particular
gene does and we have another in the
front row yes funny question your
develop the motor patterns that allowed
me have a site you know and it's been my
experience you know over all these years
and what we're talking about is juggling
and that many people who are jugglers
are involved in in mathematics in some
form or another can you think of s so um
I mean a question is you know what is
the relation there is it a kind of
environmental thing there's their
genetic thing that predisposes people to
be both interested in juggling and
mathematics there's also a lot of
musicians and I I think that there is in
fact some deep affinity I don't know you
know the exact mechanism there but I
have a thought about that which is
Darwin talked about the idea of descent
with modification the idea is you take
something that was there and you modify
in some way to build something new
Francois Jacob who helped discover the
idea that genes were if ifs and then at
a great metaphor of evolution as a
tinkerer so what you find is that basic
ideas for building particular structures
get used over and over again so my
favorite example is the hand and the
foot are basically evolved from a common
origin their slight variations on a
theme there may be genetic themes for
building musical structures and rhythm
structures and so forth they get played
out both in mathematical reasoning and
in certain motor patterns like juggling
so it may not be an accident that you
find same same people having common sets
of predispositions
anyone else please raise your hand Gary
when a stroke hits a part of the brain
from what you have said my understanding
is that it not only would affect that
area but because of the complexity of
the brain that a lot of other things
could be affected aside from that
definitely I mean as a scientist rather
than a doctor that's to my chagrin
because it means that whenever we do
these studies where we say oh well when
this person had a stroke and blood was
not flowing to Broca's area they don't
talk anymore we want to tell these
simple stories a hot Broca's areas
what's responsible for language but it
turns out that the blood flow doesn't
fall so neatly on a single area and then
every area is interacting with other
areas and so forth so it makes life for
scientists very difficult and of course
it makes life for anybody who suffers
from a stroke enormously difficult so
the whole brain is this very complicated
interdependent system it would be that
way even without jeans because all the
circuitry is interconnected in
complicated ways and then when we throw
in the fact that genes are active
throughout life and are responsive to
what can be going on in other parts of
the brain it turns to be very
complicated and there's no simple way to
say well you know this area this is the
only thing that's going to happen
another question
yes this concept of Amharic this concept
of heritability is a little confusing to
me there's a there's a technical term
heritability which is basically the
relation between variation between
individuals and genetic relatedness so
when the bell curve came out there was a
lot of talk about heritability in the
news so this book by Marie Marie and
Arnstein about racial differences and
whether they might be genetic and so
forth heritability is a statistical
measure that's fairly easy to calculate
but it's very complicated to understand
I have a few pages and in the first
chapter to talk about exactly what it
means but basically if you find the two
identical twins are more similar on some
traits a than non-identical twins then
the heritability is going to be
reasonably high it's usually metric
between zero and one that doesn't really
matter the problems come in when you
interpret that measure the first thing
is it's actually about variation between
individuals it doesn't say anything
about the genetic components that might
be shared across all human beings so
people talk about heritability of IQ for
example and it's sort of like looking at
only the treetops or something like that
I mean every human being is very
different safe from every chimpanzee and
that doesn't enter into the equation the
only thing that enters into the equation
is the little differences between
individuals Chomsky likes to talk about
how a Martian scientist if they looked
at human beings would say they're not
really that different it's just like a
bunch of frogs or something like that
there's so much in common with human
beings they all have language they all
have some kind of religious rituals in
any kind of culture that you might see
or something that stands in for that an
enormous similarities across human
beings they're all roughly the same
height and you know we care about little
differences in height with our
basketball teams but from the
perspective of the Martian scientist
there's not that much variation in human
being so then you look at the
heritability measure and it's all about
just the variation between human beings
so that's kind of the first reason to
have pause when interpreting the measure
the measure tells us something I mean if
we find that IQ is heritable as it
indeed it is 50% heritability or
something like that that tells you that
genes really have
some kind of effect some kind of causal
effect that in some way influences the
differences between individuals but it
doesn't mean what we intuitively think
it means it doesn't mean that fifty
percent of intelligence comes from the
genes anything like that I can go on
more but I think you want to follow up
or something like that specific question
like the behavior shanetta Sesay if
you're a potato giving trait yep I'm
sorry I'm sorry if you take the behavior
geneticists say that it could take a
specific trait mm-hmm um that but you
compare it you compare this trade
amongst a group of people that roughly
fifty percent is due to genetics twenty
fifty percent of the variation between
those individuals those people fifty
percent is genetics and fifty great says
nothing about there's nothing about the
shared aspect of that tree and it also
doesn't say anything about one
individual it's about populations rather
than individual so it says as a
statistical measure I can say the
following about population it doesn't
say in this person half of its genetics
and half of its environment it's sort of
wrong to reduce it to a single number so
you can think about the examples I gave
and multiply them thirty thousand right
so each gene interacts with the
environment in a particular way and it's
just enormous over simplification to
sort of add them all up and say fifty
percent there's fifty percent that there
are millions of individual decisions
being made in individual cells based on
the genes and interaction with the
environment and so reducing it to one
number just doesn't make a lot of sense
it makes sense for certain narrow
technical purposes but I don't think in
the sort of way in which the average
person thinks about genetics it makes
sense to say well half this person is
like this and you have to remember that
it's really about variation any more
questions
I just wanted to know in in your studies
have you reached any sort of conclusions
on fighting tardy retardation and feeble
mindedness well I mean in in weeding it
out well I don't think so much in terms
of weeding it out but yeah i think that
there's lots of interesting research
nowadays to try to figure out what are
the genetic factors that influence
something like retardation so actually
there are many different disorders that
we use the colloquial term retardation
there's lots of different disorders that
can interfere with cognitive function in
the first lesson is that they're each
different so for example until a few
years ago people didn't know anything
about Williams syndrome now probably a
number of people in the audience have
heard of it ten years ago I don't think
anybody with Williams syndrome is a kind
of what people would have called mental
retardation a cognitive challenge was
probably the politically correct way to
talk about it now where people have
relatively normal language they're very
social but they don't really understand
a lot of what goes on around them and
that's a very different profile say from
people with Down syndrome who will have
not such good language won't be as
social and we'll just behave very
differently so the first thing we have
to do is to actually um if not treat
everybody as individuals which would be
the ultimate goal at least we have to
start in research purposes by dividing
the categories more finely the second
thing I would say is all the genetic
techniques that can be used say to study
heart disease can also be used to study
any kind of brain disorder a consequence
of the fact that I gave you earlier
which is that the brain and the body are
built much the same way is that a lot of
the same techniques for example for
measuring genes for tracing genes and so
forth can be used for just about any
kind of disorder whether it be of the
brain or of the body so there's lots of
techniques again on the horizon but once
again the answers are going to come
slowly time for maybe one more question
anyone know Kerry thank you very much
thank you all very much